[Music]
that's like we've collected some of the
biggest duds I could find I've bought a
whole bunch one they cost like a dollar
on and they're kind of interesting why
didn't they sell this one I don't know
why it didn't sell what's called
unimpressive virtual reality experiences
the big book there's a guy redeeming a
Bed Bath and Beyond coupons he's losing
his mind as I leave this guy right there
drinking tea that's a little too 500
your mind yeah look at this guy right
here I like him installing a child car
seat so frustrated that'll freak you out
and discovering your sandwich has onions
on it when you specifically requested no
onions these are all check this one out
cartoon villains who just got laid now
look at that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like the Smurfs were low though
good yeah oh my god well they are evil
they are evil and then finally I like to
see Skeletor II he's having to go you
got to lift that flap if you know what I
mean what the hell it's a flap yeah I
got what you have an eye did you you
like manga right well I love manga all
right
gravy manga with pink I wouldn't even
want to touch that Oh what are you
talking about this one very conceptual I
can maybe see why this one wasn't a big
seller the big book of black and it's
got all the different tones you would
possibly want it features evany right
you've got your cold
you've got your crow yeah and then
you've got your sharpie right there and
folks we debated this one at rehearsal
and we said let's go for it
oh it went in the ocean it went in the
real ocean that's there's some hobo
sleeping back there check this one out
Satan's favorite photos of Mike Huckabee
playing bass hey a lot of photos here of
just Mike and his mic got the beat
playing bass photos I love this book and
finally I love this one Triple X gourds
these are gorg or the triple x feel to
them and I don't know what and then
check this one out and that's just
[Applause]
oh it gets better
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography